on june 23 1853
two men would set in motion one of the
most ambitious urban projects in history
changing the city of light
a team had to be assembled
in charge houseman and louis napoleon
the former a flamboyant nearly two meter
tall megalomaniac was appointed as
prefect of the sand
in the latter a bonaparte in public and
hobbyist urban planner in private
beneath them some of the most brilliant
architects landscape designers and water
managers that history has ever provided
on paper their strategy was to create
new ordered space in the cramped and
nasty parisian streets so they began by
completing what the first napoleon could
not
the grand cross of paris
this meant completing the route of
rivoli from east to west as well as
constructing a similar north to south
connection
these roads cut through thousands of
homes and revealed a sinister
personality behind that of the urban
planer one of ruthless drive for
perspective and symmetry
housman's boulevards had a reputation
for being wide and dramatic it's true
that was always part of the plan
narrow dark streets mean easily
constructed barricades a wide boulevard
means that rebellers now require much
more
material the boulevard richard lenoir
for example was purely strategic built
to cut through radical prone parts of
the city by paving over part of the
canal saint martin a stronghold for
rebels at the time
but for housman highly dense urban areas
also meant that prize jewels could not
be awarded their proper perspectives so
he designed his networks in order to
produce focal points his boulevards were
not merely defined by being wide with
little deviation they were defined by
what they directed attention to
now
it's important to understand that
hausmann was no simple man
he was an obsessive
on the right bank of the sen a bridge
begins and the newly constructed
supestable road placed by him did not
perfectly line up with it
for many this would have been tolerable
i mean who cares city goers are usually
more interested in reaching their
destination than admiring whether the
streets line up but houseman was a
different ape
so he commanded david to construct an
entire building with the sole purpose of
making the bridge seem more evenly
placed between two roads rather than off
center from one
for the green spaces of paris housemen
decided on two large parks outside the
ring and two smaller parks within it in
addition to the green space of city
squares and boulevards
of the new parks though two deserve the
most attention
the first the bologna located outside
the periphery it may not be one of the
first things in mind to visit for the
average tourist but it should be
louis napoleon had a deep admiration for
the architectural work of john nash in
the green space design in london like
hyde park
in fact houseman and louis napoleon
modeled much of their renovations off of
london unique because it meant admitting
that france didn't invent everything the
design of the park was led by alfond and
like houseman he was also hyper-focused
accounts go so far that alphon tried to
specify the type of sand to be used on
pathways so that it wouldn't be too
abrasive for the skin of playing
children
the park he designed featured an
elaborate network of streams lakes and
cascades which required an elaborate
water supply so a fawn commanded the
construction of around 66 000 meters of
irrigated pipes with almost 2 000
hydrants and spigots installed every 30
to 40 meters
the result completely unconventional
an intricate landscape built for people
in the city but filled with ponds lakes
and rivelettes
it outshone the london parks that
preceded it and inspired the
recognizable parks that succeeded it
located in the 19th borough is an
unassuming crescent built on top of a
quarry
before going further we need to
understand some geology
dear morning brew
i don't want to come off as someone
that's been brainwashed by american
culture but i'm writing this art to tell
you that i
i love you
i wait for your five minute free and
daily email newsletter on business
finance and tech every single morning
there is no other newsletter like you
but i also want you to know that i
sponsored you before you even asked me
to says to morning brew one of the most
successful american business newsletters
with over 3 million subscribers it's not
just that i adore news that isn't
pretentious or the fact that your daily
newsletter makes me come off as though i
know a thing or two when i try to prove
myself to other human beings in a social
competition that's completely irrelevant
in the totality of existence but it's
also that i can experience your content
in the most frictionless way possible by
for example clicking the link in the
description the pinned comment or just
searching the morningbrewdaily.com
huge
paris is located in the creatively named
paris basin the former location of a
shallow warm tropical sea that produced
sedimentary rock gypsums and limestones
across the basin there are multiple
limestone deposits and limestone can
vary significantly in terms of porosity
and strength different areas use
different limestones
so for example and also because this
visual looks cool some smaller areas in
the paris basin may rely on a less
porous russet red limestone whereas
others will rely on a more porous gray
limestone
although color clearly demarcates some
buildings within the basin the reason
why architectural feats in different
cities can seem materially
indistinguishable is because of their
reliance on a specific limestone and
layer paris does have its own deposits
within its ring which were also used to
construct many of its iconic buildings
but much of the limestone that composed
housman's new buildings actually came
from a city north of paris
limestone was an easily accessible
building material
which made it more affordable but this
changed over time as the stone became
increasingly seen as a status symbol and
many of the limestone quarries in the
basin started shutting down
limestone is also a strong robust
building material that's relatively easy
to cut and shape
so it was an obvious option for the
buildings that would line houseman's
boulevards
when it came to the designs houseman was
hands off with interior but very
hands-on with exterior
buildings were standardized around six
floors the ground floor used for shops
the first for offices the second for
nobles and the rest of the floors going
up inversely with class with the upper
floors being intended for servants
there are three important features
you'll recognize but not only in paris
intricate wrought iron balconies and
cuboid roofs made of glass and zinc
all three the reflection of the second
empire style the napoleon iii exported
across the world
wrought iron was malleable and able to
resist large tensile forces and it was
used in some of the largest
architectural feats of the second empire
while also being used as park entrances
and balconies
the top floor roof of houseman's
buildings monsard a nearly flat top with
steep sloped sides
designed that way because the top floor
was practically always used as living
space and it's also the reason why
you'll usually see an array of windows
for the roof a zinc alloy a combination
of zinc copper titanium or tin
before houseman most of paris's roofs
were made of slate brought from the
loire valley
but zinc sheets were lighter cheaper
stronger recyclable and easier to
install
and zinc also has the benefit of being
self-healing which helps it last decades
and zinc sheeting can also be bent into
elaborate shapes and the slots you see
on parisian roofs are the result of
these sheets being stapled together
anyway
back to the park
within paris separated between the right
and left banks are the local mines that
were used to collect limestone in gypsum
where the left bank had larger limestone
quarries the right banks mines were
mainly used for their gypsum deposits
the park built on top of a former gypsum
quarry received its name from the lack
of vegetation that resulted from the
abundance of clay and gypsum in the soil
in order to convert the quarry dump into
a genuinely enjoyable park alfond had to
make some dramatic decisions
railroad tracks were laid in to bring in
topsoil a lake was built the grounds
were contoured by thousands of workers
and explosives were used to sculpt the
gypsum mounds as well as construct a
rocky island in the park
decorating the park was a landscape
designer deschamp the gardener-in-chief
who deserves a special mention
the style he perfected and which was
exported across the world were floral
displays featuring exotic trees and
irregular patterns of plots of different
sizes that were curved and surrounded by
similar shaped paths and winding streams
in the quarry turned park alone there
were over 47 species of plants trees and
shrubs cultivated
to maintain the steady supply of exotic
plants though was no easy task
he established nurseries dedicated to
growing perennial plants and street
trees he had specific nurseries for
deciduous trees for evergreens and
ericaceous plants and for luxury
cultivation
nearly a hundred workers tended to
thousands of plants at a single time
producing around three million plants
per year
elaborate steam heat systems were
designed in order to control temperature
and humidity levels year-round
and carts were specifically built in
order to transport mature trees both to
the parks and to the boulevards hausmann
had designed
but green spaces require more than just
the plants that populate it and across
the city's public green spaces you'll
find david's intricately designed pieces
of street furniture
for sitting he designed three types of
common benches which can be found across
the entire city
benches designed as though they were
built off the branches themselves an
attempt at blending furniture into the
landscape
double-sided benches for those wandering
through paris that also had practical
advertising purposes
and the gondola which is just a bench
david also designed newspaper kiosks the
morris column and public urinals the
legacy of his genius permeated
everywhere
but recognizable parisian street
furniture did not end with him
in the 19th century easily accessible
water for pedestrians was also a
requirement actually it has always been
and to solve that problem one of the
most iconic features of the parisian
city was born
the wallace fountain
tall enough to be visible but not enough
to be imposing dark green to blend in
with the nature and other street
furniture and made of cast iron to solve
the last two requirements affordability
and durability many of which have lasted
until today
but the wallace fountains as you can
expect from anything french have to
carry meaning beyond just carrying water
and some speculate that the different
iteration of figures on the fountains
represent different seasons and virtues
but fountains that supply water directly
also require a network that can bring it
in in the first place and this is one of
houseman's most important contributions
the french have always been known as
particularly proud people and the 1800s
were no exception most of paris's human
excrement was deemed too valuable to
wash away when it could be used as
fertilizer
what made fecal matters more complicated
though was that of the excrement that
did end up washing away a significant
amount of it ended up in the sen which
meant that parisians drew a large part
of their water supply from one of their
most significant sewers
what houseman was not opposed to however
was drastically changing the water
supply
instead of being provided water from the
inferior brackish rivers housemen sought
much purer springs but springs aren't
always immediately accessible in order
to convince the emperor to approve a
massive overhaul of the water supply
housman manipulated the emperor's
fragile ape ego by relating it to the
romans
this worked but belgrand an engineer not
politician warned that it would be
tricky
they would have to cover a massive
distance so the high quality spring
water wouldn't be tainted by gypsum
deposits
this meant that they would have to
settle for the river daos a
sub-tributary of the marn to the east of
paris and the river van to the southeast
daos was chosen at an altitude of 128
meters so that it could deliver water
via gravity to the heights in the east
of paris at an altitude of 108 meters
belgrand also introduced an innovative
opioid shape for the pipes which
concentrated and sped the movement of
liquid at low flow
they were also wide enough for a man to
move around them in order to clear
obstructions and execute repairs
fortunately there also came a time where
paris had to face its valuable waste
problem
an increasing population meant an
increased supply of waste which became
intolerable enough that adequate means
of disposal had to be arranged that
could work at scale
the combination with having to manage
storm water which housemen eventually
conceded to mix with excrement resulted
in belgrand and houseman expanding the
sewer network massively
new types of sewers were constructed on
top of the existing network along with
massive new collector sewers that were
designed to shift waste water from the
sand to downstream of the city
they also designed the sewers so that
they could be mechanically cleaned they
designed dredge boats which would flow
down sewer canals in order to clear up
build-up and they also introduced
massive iron wooden balls which would be
dropped in the canals build up pressure
and then hurtled downstream clearing
away any debris
after all of this information you may
think housman an authoritative
personality with severe ocd as well as a
ruthless control freak that destroyed
things in his way he's probably not too
controversial and luckily the french
have never had a flare for the dramatic
or rejecting authority but surprisingly
you'd be wrong
so when louis napoleon lost his power
houseman was next on the chopping block
stripped of authority and relegated to
the sidelines his legacy tainted
and plenty of people during his lifetime
or today can have or still do scream
into the void about the destruction of
what could have been or should have
stayed that didn't because of his
actions
but none of those people will have left
as much of a visible mark on the city of
light as he or his team did
before you click off i want to say that
i'm giving this book away which is
probably the most extensive written
account of houseman's impact on paris
that exists on this planet with much
much better graphics than i can give
justice to in this video it served its
purpose for me so if you want just sign
up to this newsletter i'll randomly pick
someone and send it to you and if you
win or don't you can always just
unsubscribe uh please don't but know
that it's always an option
also thanks to a bunch of academics for
providing me a substantial amount of
literature on this subject like getting
shapiro for the 492-page thesis on
alfons garden design and dr cher for the
incredibly comprehensive articles on
limestone in paris